und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
das Regierung lot an diesem Wochenende
zum Tag der offenen Tür ein also zum
Blick hinter die regierungskulissen und
auch wenn man als Bürger in den letzten
Tagen den Eindruck haben konnte dass
einem der Streit auf offener Bühne schon
als Einblick reichte kam doch viele in
die Bundesministerien und ins Kanzleramt
mal gucken wie der Olaf Scholz so in
echt ist die Devise auf Regierungsseite
war auf jeden Fall den Streit möglichst
herunter zu kochen ob Kanzler ob
Minister und Ministerin oder der
SPD-Vorsitzende im ZDF sommerinterview
Thomas Reichert
geplant war eine große Feier mit dem
Bürgern aber wie das so ist wenn man die
Türen öffnet den Streit der sonst
dahinter herrscht kann auch in die
Regierung nicht verschweigen schon gar
nicht den um die Kinder Grundsicherung
insofern freue ich mich nicht darüber
dass es nun schon wieder so öffentlich
diskutiert worden ist aber wir werden
nichts daran ändern dass wir Stück für
Stück all die wichtigen Entscheidungen
treffen damit unser Land eine gute
Zukunft hat und vielleicht gewöhnt sich
der eine oder andere dann daran erst
dann zu reden wenn die Verständigung
gelungen sind auch dem
spd-parteivorsitzenden bleibt im ZDF
sommerinterview wenig mehr als ein
weiterer Friedensappell ein FDP und
Grüne
jeder der am Kabinettstisch sitzt das
ist ja ein Privileg auch diesen tollen
Land dienen zu dürfen an dem man
Ministerin oder Minister ist und ich
erwarte von jedem dass man auch dann den
Pflichten nachgeht und dass man dazu
beiträgt und ich gehe schon davon aus
dass das alle auch gehört haben und dass
wir jetzt sehr schnell zu einer Einigung
kommen doch beim Zeiten werden wir
versprechen droht schon der nächste
Ampel Ärger 2% der Wirtschaftsleistung
sollen mindestens für Verteidigung
ausgegeben werden Institut der berechnen
vor die Ampel hat dafür mehrere
Milliarden zu wenig eingeplant wenn wir
in den
Haushaltsentwurf schauen dann stellen
wir fest dass der Verteidigungshaushalt
gemeinsam mit dem Sondervermögen nur für
1,7 % der Wirtschaftsleistung reicht es
fehlen also 14 Milliarden Euro noch viel
gravieren der wird die Lücke wenn das
Sondervermögen nach 5 Jahren
aufgebraucht ist
muss mir das genau angucken welche
Zahlen ausgerechnet wurden was ich weiß
ist das endlich die ganzen
rüstungsprozesse die häufig wahnsinnig
lange dauern dass die beschleunigt
werden unter Pistorius dass wir die 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen geschlossen
haben und ich erwarte auch dass das Geld
jetzt ausgegeben wird klingt bei selbst
hat sich im ampelstreit bislang eher
zurückgehalten so sehr dass es zunehmend
Kritik gibt die Position der SPD werde
nicht deutlich genug zum Beispiel bei
einem Bürgergespräch vor ein paar Tagen
in Frankfurt
ich vermisse die SPD weil die Regierung
taucht auf durch Streitereien zwischen
den kleinen regierungspartnern
Koalitionspartnern die SPD als größter
Koalitionspartner ist einfach nicht
präsent im ZDF drängt klingen bei nun
auf mehr Profil und fordert Subventionen
für Industrieunternehmen angesichts hohe
Energiepreise
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir
den industriestrompreis brauchen um die
Wirtschaft hier zu stärken und die
Arbeitsplätze zu halten und neue zu
schaffen ich nehme wahr natürlich auch
wie Sie dass die FDP dagegen ist dass
der Bundeskanzler skeptisch ist aber
jetzt geht es um das zu klären und ich
halte das völlig aus dass es mal
unterschiedliche Meinung gibt zumindest
solange es ohne Streit gehe das aber ist
in der Ampel in der so eine Frage
ja eine Frage die wir mit dem
fDP-Fraktionschef Christian dürr
besprechen wollen schönen guten Abend
nach Bremen Herr dürr guten Abend Frau
gerlindek nennen Sie uns doch bitte mal
drei Eigenschaften die sie an ihrem
grünen Koalitionspartner so richtig gut
finden naja die Grünen sind mit unseren
alle Koalition gestartet die
fortschrittskoalition ist denn wir haben
in Deutschland sehr viel aufzuholen und
dann sind wir uns einig in der Sache wir
haben vieles auf den Weg gebracht denken
Sie beispielsweise an die
planungsbeschleunigung viele Jahre in
Deutschland diskutiert nichts passiert
wir ordnen die Migration nach
Deutschland in den Arbeitsmarkt nicht in
die sozialen Sicherungssysteme und ich
hätte mir gewünscht ganz offen am
vergangene Mittwoch das ist alle so
sehen wie Robert Habeck der
Bundeskanzler und wir als FDP nämlich
das Deutschland ein
wachstumschancengesetz braucht damit wir
auch wirtschaftlich durchstarten wir
sind ein sehr starkes und tolles Land
die Unternehmen brauchen aber bessere
Rahmenbedingungen das kam unter der
Vorgängerregierung zu groß aber besser
werden und es ist schade dass jetzt eine
Ministerin da ihr eventuell eingelegt
hat jedenfalls vorläufig genau
Verlässlichkeit haben sie nicht als
Eigenschaft aufgezähl die sie an den
Grünen schätzen Hintergrund meiner Frage
ist natürlich das offenbar ziemlich
vergiftete Koalitionsklima in der Ampel
warum fällt der FDP das Regieren mit den
Grünen so wahnsinnig schwer nein das ist
ja in der Sache vom vergangenen Mittwoch
sie sprechen ja auf die
kabinettsentscheidung an da ist ein
großes Paket verabschiedet worden aber
es fehlte das wachstumschancengesetz was
alle sagen wir brauchen es die
Unternehmen in Deutschland die
Wirtschaftsverbände sagen dass die
Forschungsinstitute und natürlich auch
große Teile der Koalition und es waren
sicher auch der Bundeskanzler der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister von den Grünen
und Finanzminister Christian Lindner wir
von der FDP uns alle einig es war eine
Ministerin die ihr wehtor eingelegt hat
was ich schade finde denn wir könnten
jetzt richtig durchstarten die Sache ist
nur aufgeschoben nicht aufgehoben ich
bin sicher das Gesetz wird kommen es ist
notwendig und im übrigen das will ich
kurz sagen Frau gerlindek weil die
Familienministerin zu Recht auch auf
Kinderarmut hinweist die das größte
Risiko für kinderarmut ist ja die
Arbeitslosigkeit der Eltern und da
müssen wir besser werden dass mehr
Menschen im Jobs kommen und das heißt
wachst und an der Stelle glaube ich wird
sie sich eines Besseren besinnen hoffe
ich jedenfalls und ich würde mich freuen
wenn die Grünen sich da intern einig
werden wie gesagt das ist kein Diskurs
so sehr zwischen FDP und Grünen sondern
er hat in der eher innerhalb der Grünen
Partei jetzt aber hat Frau Paust ja
einen Gesetzesentwurf vorgelegt wie wir
wie wir hören und da kursiert die Zahl
von 3,5 Milliarden jährlich das klingt
ja als ob sie sich auf die FDP zu bewegt
unterdessen hat ihr Parteichef Christian
Lindner Finanzminister heute ja die
Sinnfrage gestellt ob die Kinder
Grundsicherung überhaupt der richtige
Weg ist das klingt ja so als ob sie sich
jetzt nicht einigen wollen ich will das
kurz einordnen ich sagte vorhin schon
den ersten wichtigen Punkt die
Arbeitslosigkeit der Eltern ist das
größte Risiko für Kinderarmut in
Deutschland und da müssen wir besser
werden mehr Wachstumschancen das
erwähnte ich vor und ich bin sicher dass
das entsprechende Gesetz bald kommen
wird zum zweiten ist es so dass man
schon die Frage stellen muss ob einfach
nur höhere sozial Transfer sind
Deutschland ist ja international da auf
dem Spitzenplatz sie haben hohe
Sozialleistungen in Deutschland ob das
schon reicht gegen Kinderarmut oder ob
wir nicht über bessere Bildungschancen
reden müssen mehr Förderunterricht mehr
Sprachförderung und zum dritten und das
ist der Kern der Kindergrundsicherung
wir fassen alle familienpolitischen
Leistungen eine Leistung zusammen es ist
bisher sehr unübersichtlich in
Deutschland für Familien gerade für die
die schwerer haben und da den Kindern
guter Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen das
ist ja das Ziel Entbürokratisierung das
ganze auch digitaler zu machen das haben
wir uns als Koalition auf die Fahnen
geschrieben solche bürokratischen
Vorgänge viel einfacher zu machen und da
sind wir uns einig und ich hoffe dass
genau das der Gesetzentwurf von Frau
Pause auch leisten wird aber das was ihr
Parteichef heute gesagt hat ist ja dass
er noch mal ganz grundsätzlich über die
Kindergrundsicherung nachdenken will das
klingt ja nicht als ob das jetzt schnell
als ob der Streit schnell beigelegt
werden könnte ja mir ist wichtig da zwei
Dinge zu unterscheiden das eine
Kindergrundsicherung kommen soll ist
richtig und gut und da geht es um
Entbürokratisierung wir haben schon
Leistung die werden teilweise gar nicht
abgerufen die kommen bei den Familien
die brauchen nicht an und das soll die
Kindergrundsicherung leisten Frau Paus
wird zusätzlich noch höhere
Sozialtransfers da habe ich vorhin
angemerkt ob dieses Geld nicht besser in
Bildung investiert ist wir wissen ja
dass wir da einiges aufzuholen haben
also bessere Bildungschancen am Start
des Lebens und das ist das was Christian
Lindner zu Recht anspricht aus meiner
Sicht bessere Bildungschancen statt
einfach nur höhere Sozialtransfers dann
hat Ricarda lang die Copa teilchefin der
Grünen heute noch mal dafür plädiert die
Schuldenbremse zu umgehen und dann
stattdessen öffentliche öffentliche
investitionsgesellschaften ins Spiel
gebracht ist das ein Instrument was für
Sie in Frage kommt für notwendige
Zukunftsinvestition ja das hat mich auch
ein bisschen gewundert ähnlich wie der
das weh tut von Frau Paust denn mit der
Schuldenbremse und der Einhaltung das
steht ja nicht nur ein Grundgesetz
sondern wir sind es doch politisch
eigentlich Robert Habeck verteidigt
regelmäßig zu Recht die Schuldenbremse
wie wir das als FDP auch seit vielen
Jahren tun einfach nur mehr Schulden
machen das wird nicht bringen und eins
muss man wissen bei der Frage der
Investitionstätigkeit in Deutschland 9
von 10 Euro die werden von der
Privatwirtschaft investiert nicht vom
Staat das heißt wenn der Starter was
macht das bringt gar nicht so viel wir
brauchen mehr private Investitionen und
da da schließt sich der Kreis da geht es
um das wachstumschancengesetz was wir
eingangs besprachen nämlich das Gesetz
was besseres Standortbedingungen für
Deutschland schaffen sollte deswegen
muss das ganz schnell kommen dann wird
mehr investiert und dann haben wir auch
mehr wirtschaftlichen Erfolg und das
kommt am Ende wie gesagt auch Kindern
zugute da stoßen ja dann doch zwei
Weltanschauungen aufeinander wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe ihr Parteichef
Christian Lindner hat ja mal gesagt es
sei besser nicht zu regieren als
schlecht zu regieren die Bürger finden
dass die Ampel im Moment sehr schlecht
regiert wie lange geben Sie der
Koalition noch diese Koalition macht im
Grundsatz eine sehr gute Arbeit das
Problem war wirklich am vergangenen
Mittwoch das eine Ministerin eingesetzt
angehalten hat und das war ich glaube
Lars klingen bei sagt es heute im Sommer
Interview bei Ihnen auch der SPD-Chef
das war ein grober Fehler und
unverständlich weil wir waren uns bei
allen anderen Dingen denken Sie
beispielsweise an das Thema mehr
oder Entbürokratisierung bei
Solaranlagen und so weiter und so fort
da ist ja am Mittwoch viel beschlossen
worden mehr Unterstützung für Start-ups
bessere Rahmenbedingungen und so weiter
also gibt es viel Einigkeit in der Sache
und es ist jetzt ärgerlich dass ein
Punkt dann aussieht wie Streit nach
außen das hätte man hinter den Kulissen
klären müssen deswegen wundert mich das
Frau Paust das zur öffentlich gemacht
hat und mein Eindruck ist Frau Gellinek
innerhalb der Grünen gibt es da
unterschiedliche Ansichten
unterschiedliche Lager deswegen sich die
Koalition im Prinzip einig und mein
Appell lautet dass die Grünen sich
intern einig werden und ich glaube dann
wird das Bild nach außen der Koalition
auch deutlich besser
Christian Dörr sagt die Grünen sind
Schuld wenig überraschend für einen
fDP-Fraktionschef vielen Dank für das
Gespräch und einen schönen Sonntagabend
ich danke Ihnen Frau Gerling
und hier geht's weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula Gause und die
beginnen mit den Waldbränden auf
Teneriffa der Feuerwehr gelingt es nur
in einzelnen Brandabschnitten die
Flammen einzudämmen insgesamt breiten
sich die Brände auf Teneriffa weiterhin
aus mittlerweile sind rund 10.000 Hektar
Land zerstört starker Wind und anhalten
hohe Temperaturen erschweren die
Löscharbeiten ganze Ortschaften im
Nordosten Teneriffas wurden evakuiert
Urlauber im Süden der Insel sind nicht
betroffen die Polizei ermittle auch in
Richtung Brandstiftung erklärte der
regionalpräsident
und auch in Kanada brennt es weiterhin
an über 1.000 Stellen dort verschärft
sich die Situation weil sich in British
Columbia zwei große Waldbrände zu einem
riesigen Feuer von mehr als 40.000
Hektar vereint haben sollen aber auch
aus Kanada gibt es bislang keine
Berichte über Todesopfer denn auch dort
ordnen die Behörden Evakuierungen an
überschattet vom Mord an einem
Oppositionskandidaten findet im
politischen instabilen Ecuador die erste
Runde der Präsidentschaftswahlen statt
unter großen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen so
wurden an den Wahlbüros Soldaten zur
Absicherung eingesetzt als Favoritin
gilt die 45-Jährige Luise Gonzales aus
dem linken Lager beobachte rechnen mit
einer Stichwahl im Oktober
Dänemark und die Niederlande werden der
Ukraine F16 Kampfjets liefern zuvor
hatte Washington die Genehmigung für die
Entsendung der us-jets erteilt der
ukrainische Präsident selenski dankte
beim Besuch bei der Länder für die
Unterstützung Dänemarks
Ministerpräsidentin Frederiksen zu Folge
werden derzeit 70 ukrainische Piloten an
F16 in Dänemark ausgebildet silensky
rechnet mit 42 der Jets wann genau sie
geliefert werden ist noch unklar
Russlands erste Mondmission seit fast 50
Jahren ist gescheitert eigentlich sollte
die Raumsonde Luna 25 morgen auf dem
Mond landen nach einer außerplanmäßigen
Situationen so die russische
Raumfahrtbehörde rosskosmos sei die
sonder aber auf der Mondoberfläche
aufgeschlagen und habe aufgehört zu
existieren gestartet war die Mission vor
gut einer Woche die Ursache des
Aufpralls soll nun eine Kommission
klären eine erfolgreiche Landung auf dem
Mond ist bislang nur der Sowjetunion den
USA und China gelungen
die weltraumprogramme der Großmächte
waren immer schon Prestige Vorhaben die
die Überlegenheit des eigenen Systems
beweisen sollten der Staat der
russischen Mondsonde Lunar 25 ist da
keine Ausnahme sollte er doch zeigen
dass Russlands Raumfahrt trotz
Sanktionen zu Höchstleistungen fähig ist
die Botschaft auch wir Russland lassen
uns nicht unterkriegen nicht in der
Ukraine nicht im Weltraum zum Absturz
der Mondsonde gab es heute keinen
Kommentar aus dem Kreml dem staatlich
propagierten russischen Patriotismus
aber hat das keinen Abbruch getan
Armee 2023 heißt eine Ausstellung in der
Nähe von Moskau die mit Militärtechnik
die Siegesgewissheit der Streitkräfte
demonstrieren soll und die Moskauer
strömten
ich bin Patriot steht da geschrieben und
Patrioten sind hier viele vor den Toren
Moskaus können die heute in Augenschein
nehmen was das größte Land der Welt
waffenmäßig zu bieten hat alle Jahre
wieder findet dieses Spektakel statt
dieses Mal überschattet von einem
Ereignis das im Nachbarland Ukraine
stattfindet und niemand hier beim Namen
nennt
beeindruckend stark und kraftvoll man
sieht sofort dass wir unseren Staat
verteidigen können dass es Grenzen gibt
die niemand jemals überschreiten kann
das was wir seit dem Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion verloren haben müssen wir
wieder herstellen das ist schwierig aber
notwendig wir müssen aufrüsten und so
für mehr Anerkennung sorgen
die Anerkennung des Westens darum kämpft
Russland seit Jahrhunderten der T14
armata der Stolz der Streitkräfte auch
im Einsatz in der Ukraine die Berührung
scheint Kraft zu spenden und auch der
Griff zum Gewehr dass Gott sei Dank
Attrappe ist
ich bin stolz auf unser Land wenn ich
all die Technik und die Ausrüstung sehe
dass wir das alles in Russland haben das
gibt mir Kraft
wie Trophäen die Waffen des Westens die
Russland in der Ukraine zerstört und
erbeutet haben will davor Spielzeug die
Botschaft die Ukraine schießt mit
westlichen Waffen auf Kinder Russlands
Verteidigungsminister nutzt die Bühne um
die Werbetrommel zu rühren
unsere Waffen zeigen ihre
Zuverlässigkeit und Wirksamkeit
gegenüber den hochgepriesenen Systemen
des Westens von deren Schwäche Sie sich
hier in der Ausstellung überzeugen
können
auch China hat einen Stand auf der Messe
ob es beim Nein zu Waffenlieferungen
bleibt das liest der eigens angereiste
Verteidigungsminister offen als er in
seiner Rede in Moskau den
Schulterschluss betont mit Russland und
gegen die USA
um die Welt sicherer zu machen müssen
wir zusammen stehen und uns gegen die
globalen hegemonialansprüche einzelner
wenden um die Welt gerechter zu machen
müssen wir alle Versuche der Ausgrenzung
abwehren
der Kreml erhofft sich von der Messe
Waffen Deals in Höhe von 4 Milliarden
Euro Geld dass das sanktionsgeplante
Land auch braucht für seine
Militäraktion die heute keiner hier beim
Namen nennt und um seinem Volk das
Gefühl der Überlegenheit zu geben im
Jahrhunderte alten Kräfte messen mit dem
Westen
während Moskau also weiterhin so tut als
ob der Krieg in der Ukraine eine saubere
spezialoperation ohne große Verluste sei
werden bei Menschen die den Zweiten
Weltkrieg noch miterlebt haben
schlimmste Erinnerungen wach bei den
sogenannten wolfskindern zum Beispiel
deutsche Kinder die sich ohne Eltern vor
der vorrückenden Roten Armee aus
Ostpreußen in die Wälder Litauens
flüchteten Kinder die sich wie Romulus
und Remus in der Sage ohne die Hilfe
Erwachsener durchschlagen mussten die
die überlebten fanden im sowjetisch
besetzten Litauen Unterschlupf bei
Bauern die sie versteckten und ihnen
litauische Namen gaben ein
Dokumentarfilm versucht das Schicksal
der letzten Wolfskinder festzuhalten
christoph hat ihn gesehen
einst auch Memelland genannt hier
kämpften am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
mehr als 7000 deutsche Kinder ums nackt
überleben hier in den Wäldern
Ostpreußens und in den Feldern Litauens
[Musik]
haben wir dann Katzen und Hunde gegessen
andere sagten sie hätten Ratten gegessen
ich nicht ich habe nur Katzen und Hunde
gegessen
herr vergib mir ich dachte manchmal wir
wären besser alle gestorben
aber man hat uns auch deshalb Wölfe
getauft weil wir wie hungrige Wölfe
waren so blieben wir die Wolfskinder
Töpfer kümmert sich seit einem
Vierteljahrhundert um die vergessenen
Wolfskinder aus eigener Tasche hat er
Berliner einen beeindruckenden Film
produzieren lassen etwa 25 weißen Kinder
leben noch die letzte Generation sie
sprechen alle litauisch Deutsch haben
sie verlernt es ist ein besonderer Film
warum unter der Maßgabe dass dieser Film
nur mit dem Wolfskinder gestaltet wird
keine Reporter dabei sind die das
Interpretieren Nachfragen stören
Zweifel haben das wollte ich nicht haben
Anfang 1945 erobert die Rote Armee aus
Preußen zurückbleiben
135.000 deutsche darunter 10.000 Voll-
und Halbwaisen Kinder des Krieges den
die Flucht nach Westen nicht gelungen
war
das
kam zu uns die Russen bombardierten uns
überrollten und sozusagen und jagten uns
fort
meine Schwester liebten sie im
schweinetrog obendrauf
viele Wolfskinder suchen in Liter und
Schutz nicht wenige Bauern retteten sie
oft entschied das reine Glück der Preis
die Kinder durften kein Wort Deutsch
sprechen sie wurden litauisch
[Musik]
es gab gute Menschen und es gab
schlechte an den schlechten Lages dass
ich im Wald übernachten musste ich habe
auch auf Friedhöfen geschlafen
auch nach der Wende hat den wolfskindern
offiziell niemand geholfen die deutschen
Behörden zeigten keine Entschädigung
Begründung die Kinder waren nicht
interniert sie liebten frei in den
Wäldern
gegenüber diesen armseligen Kindern
die wirklich an nichts Schuld haben drei
mal drei ist neune weiß ja wie jetzt
meine zehn zippeln es bleibt stehen
bleibt stehen sie rührten sich sicher
den 60 °c
[Musik]
und wir machen weiter mit Nachrichten
und die kommen vom sportkontoler in der
Fußball-Bundesliga hat Eintracht
Frankfurt das hessen-duell gegen
Aufsteiger Darmstadt 98 gewonnen 1:0 und
zuvor gelang Union Berlin ein
glücklicher Saisonstart 4:1 gegen Mainz
05 die Vorrunde der Hockey
Europameisterschaft in Mönchengladbach
läuft weiter gut für die Frauen
Nationalmannschaft sie gewannen auch ihr
zweites Spiel nach dem 4:0 gegen
Schottland hieß der entstand gegen
England heute
5:02 mal erfolgreich Jette fleischütz
auch mit diesem Tor nächster Gegner am
Dienstag Irland
[Applaus]
Tennisprofi Alexanders wäre das
Halbfinale des ATP Turniers in
Cincinnati gegen Novak Djokovic knapp
verloren sechs zu sieben und fünf zu
sieben damit kommt es Ohio kurz vor den
US Open zum Traum Finale Djokovic gegen
den Spanier Carlos
bei der Leichtathletik Weltmeisterschaft
in Ungarn gab es auch heute keine
Medaille für das deutsche Team Highlight
Wettkampf des Tages war das 100 m Finale
der Männer schnellster mit 9,83 Sekunden
der US-Amerikaner Noahs auf dem zweiten
Platz nur wenige Hundertstel langsamer
letziele tobogo aus Botswana der einzige
deutsche Starter Julian Wagner aus
Erfurt kam über den Vorlauf nicht hinaus
vor Glück weinende Spanierinnen und zu
Tode betrübte Engländerinnen das sind
die schlussbilder dieses WM-Finales
Spanien also zum ersten Mal Weltmeister
im Frauenfußball diese WM war in vieler
Hinsicht etwas Besonderes mit Zuschauer
Rekorden in den Stadien von Neuseeland
und Australien und weltweiten
Traumquoten im TV aber auch mit
sportlichen Highlights und einem
spannenden Finale und natürlich schwingt
immer das Thema Gleichberechtigung
zwischen Mann und Frau mit dass die
Deutschen in der Gruppenphase nach Hause
fahren mussten ist auch Teil dieser
besonderen WM martin Wolf mit einer
ersten Bilanz
die neuen Titelträgerinnen aus Spanien
haben den am schwersten zu erringenden
Frauenfußball WM-Titel aller Zeiten
gewonnen denn nie zuvor gab es derart
viele starke Teams die heftig
kritisierte Ausweitung auf 32 Nationen
war ein voller Erfolg die meisten der
vermeintlich viel zu kleine Nationen
absolut konkurrenzfähig Kolumbien etwa
als Stolperstein für mit Favorit
Deutschland
Nigeria wiederum hätte im Achtelfinale
um ein Haar die späteren WM Finalistin
aus England aus dem Turnier geworfen
zweimal Latten Pech erst nach
Elfmeterschießen verpassten sie das
Viertelfinale nur deshalb durften
Englands Fans bis zum heutigen Finale
auf den Titel hoffen in den gelingt
Lauren ham gegen Spanien fast die
Führung die Antwort ist Teams von Jorge
Villas aber voll prompt in der 17 Minute
scheiter drehtondo nur am groß Reflex
der überragenden englischen Torfrau Mary
earths doch selbst die ist 12 Minuten
später absolut machtlos gegen den
technisch herausragenden Schuss von
Linksfuß Olga
absolute Präzisionsarbeit der
23-Jährigen von Real Madrid kurz vor der
Pause erhöht Salma fast noch auf zwei zu
null das liegt dann in der 69 Minute in
der Luft Handspiel der englischen Nummer
vier Kira Wolf Elfmeter Spanien nach
Videobeweis doch Jenny amoso scheitert
an Englands Torfrau Mary earth
die beste Chance noch den Ausgleich und
eine Verlängerung zu erzwingen hat
Lauren James
doch auf Spaniens Torfrau katakol
bestätigt dass es immer mehr überragende
Torhüterinnen gibt noch so eine
Erkenntnis dieser WM und weil wir schon
dabei sind zeigen wir vom Finale zuletzt
auch noch diesen krachenden Weitschuss
von titana Technik und Explosivität noch
nie haben wir so viele gute
Distanzschüsse gesehen während wir diese
Variante von Deutschland nur mal kurz
vorm Ausscheiden durch Sydney Lohmann
geboten bekam verwöhnten uns andere
Teams in nie gesehen im Ausmaß mit
Fernschüssen die Niederländerinnen etwa
und auch die großartigen australischen
Gastgeberinnen mit dem wohl
spektakulärsten Treffer dieser WM durch
ihren Superstar same ein vortreffliches
Sinnbild der frisch geweckten Fußball
Begeisterung down under
für die australischen Fans waren vier am
Ende fast so wertvoll wie der erstmalige
Titel gewinnen für die vermuten
Spanierin
die spanische Frauen Nationalmannschaft
bekommt übrigens seit letztem Jahr das
gleiche Geld wie die Männer in
Deutschland gibt es nach wie vor
unterschiedliche Prämien für Herren und
Damen
und wie immer am Sonntagabend schauen
wir jetzt noch mal nach vorn auf die
Ereignisse der nächsten Woche
zusammengestellt von Christian Rufus
[Musik]
erst Hitze und Dürre und dann sehr viel
Regen zuletzt die deutschen Landwirte
schauen mit gemischten Gefühlen auf die
ernte-ergebnisse in diesem Jahr am
Dienstag gibt's die ersten Zahlen der
Getreide und Obst Ernte etwa hat der
nasse Sommer nicht gerade gut getan
ebenfalls am Dienstag kommen die
sogenannten brix-staaten zusammen
Russland Indien Brasilien China und
Südafrika beraten 2 Tage in Johannesburg
unter anderem ob sie weitere Mitglieder
in das Bündnis aufnehmen wollen Chinas
Präsident hier reist an putin wird sich
nur per Video zuschalten wegen eines
laufenden internationalen Haftbefehls
am Mittwoch wollen wieder tausende
computerspiel-fans zur gamescom nach
Köln um die neuesten Trends zu sehen und
bis Ende der Woche anzuspielen die
Gaming Unternehmen sind in den
corona-jahren auch in Deutschland stark
gewachsen jetzt will der Bund die
Förderung kürzen die Branche fürchtet
einen Wettbewerbsnachteil
und das Wetter in der neuen Woche bringt
hohe Temperaturen der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt für morgen in der
Südhälfte Vorteils extremer Hitze der
Montag wird sehr sonnig nur im Nordosten
teils heiterteils etwas wolkiger im
Norden 23 bis 29 Grad im Süden schwül
bei 30 bis 35 Grad in den kommenden
Tagen hoch sommerlich mit viel Sonne und
nur einzelnen Gewittern dazu vor allem
im Süden heiß und schwül ab Donnerstag
Wetter Umschwung
das war es von uns für diese Woche hier
geht's weiter mit der thriller-serie das
Mädchen und die Nacht nächste
Nachrichten gibt es dann um 0:30 Uhr in
einer heute Express und Morgen begrüßen
Sie hier Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolf
einen schönen Abend und Tschüss auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]